welcome back to CBS mornings it's day
three of soccer's World Cup but
controversy continues to dog the host
nation Qatar the captains from Seven
teams had planned to wear a rainbow one
love armband during matches they wanted
to show support for diversity and
inclusivity in a country that limits the
rights of lgbtq people but they were
forced to back down after threats of
disciplinary action on the field by
soccer's governing body Holly Williams
looks at how the conservative Islamic
nation's treatment of members of the
lgbtq community is affecting the world
of soccer
Stonewall FC in London says it's the
world's most successful LGBT plus soccer
club
they take the game very seriously
they're looking forward to the World Cup
but they're all so worried because the
host country Qatar is a conservative
Islamic Nation where sex outside of
marriage is illegal and homosexuality
can be punishable by death I know for a
fact there would be no circumstance that
I'd be comfortable in Qatar attending
the World Cup going to matches I feel
it's been tarnished tarnished by the
legacy of a country that has so much
work to do the ruler of Qatar insists
everyone is welcome at the World Cup
including gay soccer fans the World Cup
is a great opportunity for people from
different parts of the world to come and
experience our culture we welcome
everybody but also we expect and we want
people to respect our culture but Dr Naz
Muhammad says he was the first Qatari to
come out publicly as gay earlier this
year and claims he received death
threats as a result he lives and
practices medicine in San Francisco how
frightening was it for you to come out
as a Qatari very honestly I have never
been so afraid
he believes he'd be arrested if he went
back to Qatar Qatar does not have their
resources right now during the World Cup
to go out of their way hunting LGBT
people so what you're saying is this is
a show this is a veneer Qatar is going
to welcome foreign fans who may be gay
whilst continuing to persecute gay
qataris yes so they have to accept when
one of qatar's World Cup ambassadors was
interviewed by German television the
veil slipped as he suggested
homosexuality was a sickness because the
damage in the mind
members of Australia's World Cup team
recently made this video but in Qatar
people are not free to love the person
that they choose demanding Qatar change
its laws and the decriminalization of
all same-sex relationships
but Soccer Star David Beckham has drawn
condemnation for signing a lucrative
deal to promote Qatar and its World Cup
Qatar really is an incredible place to
spend a few days on Stonewall FC they're
disappointed I think he's made an
absolutely Monumental era of judgment in
signing up to be an ambassador for the
World Cup she's being sold for just what
is just another zero in his bank account
which would make no difference to him I
think it's a complete sellout
we reached out to David Beckham for his
side of the story but he never got back
to us he recently claimed however that
the World Cup would be a platform for
progress and tolerance Tony
Holly Williams for us with an
eye-opening report from London Holly
thank you very much uh it doesn't seem
very tolerant no uh you know it's
illegal uh infidelity's illegal
homosexuality is illegal there's no
alcohol I mean it's not a free and open
Society say the least right and those
words of we embraced everybody Welcome
everybody but we expect and hope you
respect our culture it's tough because
there's a duality in there that a lot of
people can't accept well you can't refer
to homosexuality as a damage in the mind
you're right about that you can't do
that as Holly said that's true the mask
slipped there yeah yeah that's how they
really feel about that all right Holly
thank you very much